all right earl thomas comes from the
ravens the ravens have to get their
quarterback lamar jackson ready for the
season
a little bit of the concern though over
a potential injury situation with the
2019 nfl mvp here's coach john harbaugh
from yesterday
yeah we've got a couple guys uh i think
marcus peters is another one and uh
justice hill is another one who has some
soft tissue things and
just rather be safe with those guys
right now and give those things a chance
to
to get better and be right
and lamar jackson is one of those guys
that has the soft tissue thing as
john harbaugh
mentioned it now look soft tissue is a
very broad range of ligaments and
tendons and muscles and connections and
things that can aggravate for a long
time if they don't get proper rest and
properly heal chris so we're talking
about a very broad category of potential
ailments and anytime you're talking
about anything that's not entirely right
on lamar jackson you have to be
concerned if you're a ravens yeah you
got to i mean come on we know this is
one of the best players in the league
and really
again a special offense is formulated
around him and his special talents you
know that was the beauty of baltimore
it was an offense that we really have
never seen before or anything like it
you know with a quarterback we've never
seen before let alone they got good
talent on defense and other positions
too to make it all work so he is of
course huge hugely important to the
success of that football team and the
style of football in which they want to
play
and of course being that big playmaker
but this is again you know i'm my
fingers are crossed because this is what
i'm worried about it's just you know
over the last four or five days i mean
we're just seeing players just fall by
the wayside every day at practice and
these soft tissue injuries you know this
is what i worry about because of just
the lack of intense offseason training
mike you know these guys got back in
they ran wind sprints and did all some
of that stuff and then it was right to
football that's just not how a regular
off-season goes regular off-season goes
yeah wind sprints oh okay you're in
shape now let's start doing some
training that's a little more you know
football specific hey we're gonna make
you push this sled 40 yards go through
these bags push this sled pull this sled
run with this parachute connected to
your back and you get your body in all
these weird positions that are conducive
to what football is and that didn't
happen this year and that's why i'm a
little scared about the injury component
but uh harbaugh's smart he knows how to
manage a team and i think he'll play
this very safe knowing how important
jackson is
and think about the psychological aspect
of it you've got the full offseason
where
we were on lockdown and yeah there were
some guys getting workouts in but it
wasn't anything like what they
ordinarily would do they show up for
training camp and they're ready to go
they want they want to get going you
know the the elite professional athlete
does not like to be restrained he thinks
he can do everything right until he
can't and that's where you have to
strike that balance and with only 80
guys in camp we've talked about the
challenges with the 10 fewer players who
aren't available for all the reps puts a
little more stress on everyone and the
coaches are worrying about a bunch of
other issues they've never had to worry
about before as it relates to kobe 19.
so you know it it's
we we talk about it day in and day out
but they're living it day in and day out
and i think for some of these coaches
it's a lot to process
and how do you strike the right balance
how do you have the right plan how do
you properly worry about everything how
do you get your guy ready yeah
and not expose him unnecessarily to
injury chris shireen williams and i were
talking about this on friday
some of these issues remind me of that
awkward scene from hard knocks two years
ago when todd haley who was the
offensive coordinator of the browns at
the time was debating with then head
coach hugh jackson
do you give veterans maintenance days to
keep them healthy or do you just go and
get them ready and if they get injured
you deal with it and i think that
dynamic is playing out uh unlike any
other time before this year with this
urgency to get guys ready without the
benefit of preseason games in a
compressed time frame with guys who who
want to get out there and do what they
can yeah no i mean it is the juggling
act of juggling acts this year for head
coaches and managing their teams and
players that way yeah they're you can't
just you know work them into the ground
and just you know hey guys we're gonna
go after it 110 every day not in a year
like this no there's no way guys aren't
ready for that type of pounding and
punishment and let alone yeah we got
regular season football to worry about
here in a few weeks so that's an issue
so yeah i think you know coaches have to
be and just from what i know coaches are
of course managing the veteran players
to what you're talking about and being
smarter in which they in which ways they
approach practice yeah they're going to
get in some full contact full hitting
practices things like that but also find
other creative ways to get better
practicing without maybe having to exert
yourself to where you're going to
endanger yourself i think those are the
things i at least i hear from some
friends that you know coaches are
dabbling in to make up for that lack of
time and not wearing their players out
it's going to be interesting to see what
the football looks like because one
thing we've noticed in recent years as
there's been a de-emphasis on contact in
practices and contact involving tackling
to the ground the deficiencies we've
seen when it's time to go out and tackle
to the ground in a real football game
will guys be ready if coaches are airing
on the side of keeping them physically
ready to go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports